when it came for me to have my own tour
this year
um I had an nle tour in America and I
sold out like 90 of my dates like
congrats and it was huge for me because
I felt like like juice like and then I
had people that was coming the tour that
was open enough for me and I was looking
at them and it's like me yeah hoping
like four years y'all have your own [__]
going like you know what I mean that's
dope man then I went to Europe and
Canada all in this same year and I sold
out Europe completely sold out Canada
like 90 of that as well you know it was
just beautiful so I felt like I felt
like the universe was bringing you know
great blessings upon me and like versus
where I was when I was 16 just looking
at them how was Europe like what was the
craziest city in Europe you guys went to
craziest City I got to go with Tel Aviv
like it was banging on the street in
Israel right yeah it was banging on the
Sprinter when we were leaving
um it was just a beautiful experience
like very beautiful experience to see a
lot of my fans Copenhagen who was crazy
in Copenhagen
um Amsterdam I went to the red light
district I got to say that everything
did you participate in a red light
district or were you seeming retenting
at the time no I've participated really
like that [__] it was the experience I
had to first time paying for [__] how
much was it how much was it like 150
Buck 50 huh Buck 50. nice bad I was like
damn that's crazy I heard like I've
never been and I won't go because I'm
married obviously but I've heard like
certain sections of the red light
district like if you like Latin women
there's like a Latin woman section so so
it's it's it's all that people say it is
huh yeah it's beautiful it was crazy so
when you pay the 150 do they give you a
condom yeah they give you a condom and
um you come in this little room it kind
of smell like sex in more than one way
you come in a little room yeah
smell like ass like people been [__]
like people been in there beating
[__] cheeks yeah but um it was an
experience man it was pretty cheap yeah
it is pretty cheap right surprised you
didn't do the twofer man I was I was I
wanted the double it was crazy I wanted
like two of them but um one of them at
the top that was acting real bougie so I
was like I ain't gonna spend my money
with you so I went to the hub did they
know who you were
um I don't think so that's that's
probably good yeah it was like oh man I
was awesome they would have charged me
way more of course that hit you with the
rapper tax on me
that's fire so uh were you able to like
uh participate did you go to like any of
the weed cafes and [__] over there oh
yeah I went to them they had like um
they had like weed cafes I think CJ
didn't you go to the song he went to
yeah we went to it was like a coffee
weed shop it was crazy I bet you CJ had
a good [__] time yeah he had a great
time I bet he did I ain't I ain't even
smoke you know what I think I did I hit
a blunt with them that day I think I hit
a blunt with them mushrooms over there
legal too I have no clue I don't think
so I don't know might be Amsterdam's a
wild place man shout out to Amsterdam so
now shout out to
I would never experience the red light
district but
I'm living vicarious three vicariously
through you my friend